oh yeah there's there's really something
about something to be said about little
B and like that whole attitude of just
not taking yourself seriously at all and
just doing the most wacky out there [ __ ]
and just putting it out there and seeing
what happens yeah like a little B he did
it in a way where it was like his whole
everything he it seemed like he was
talking about something that was just
completely out there but then you could
all like Gucci before he went to prison
he almost did the same thing where his
lyrics were just so absurd like higher
than giraffe [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that
it's just like so ridiculous I got I got
Gucci's autobiography I don't know if
autobiography is when they write it
right yeah I think okay so I got Gucci's
but it's in it's basically in first
person it's like it's like him you know
I'm sitting talking about [ __ ] so anyway
yeah like he talks about like all that
[ __ ] like before he went to jail like he
was a lot of drugs do you know I'm
standing like when he went to jail he
lost all that weight he's not drinking
lean and [ __ ] you know I'm saying
so yeah dude it's like you know drugs
definitely cloud your mind you know I
mean you got it you can't you can't deny
the fact if that's someone that was some
of his best work when he was [ __ ] up I
feel like it's the most influential I
would say like with the stuff knows but
like that early on stuff the most
influential official cuz he got some
[ __ ] but yeah I would say that's not
classic stuff no whatever it's too much
too much ecstasy yeah pregnant belly
good yeah yeah stuffy nose congested
that's what a lot of my [ __ ] was
influenced by you know early on like
jelly was a beet bipolar boy sorry
and I was I was if you if if you looked
up Gucci Mane type beat in the
dictionary the jelly beats right there
that's the very first that's the
definition right there dude so how would
you describe a Gucci Mane beat man very
sounds like you're like a like a church
like a hood Church and it's like that
it's like the Zaytoven keys plan is like
the organ keys you know he can play a
piano or that that stupid beat change
stupid that's my favorite my favorite
either that or the original first day
out where he's in that the music video
for the original first day out that
shitty dark video where he sit in the RV
in the empty yeah because there's one
that he's in a tour van mm-hmm like he's
all Gucci downer yeah in the tour van
I think Waka Flocka at the same video in
that toy oven because welcome [ __ ] I got
a a video in a tour van it's our call
it's still standing it was like the
intro to LeBron Flocka James but yeah
man I know that whole catalog front the
back man like all Gucci [ __ ] all markets
play the big influence do you can hear
it I mean a lot of rappers that come out
with like in the meme style like that
you you know immerse yourself in they
they don't have the aggression and
delivery that you have and you can
really hear that that southern rap in
you where you're just like you're in
mic and it sounds like you're gonna like
jump through the headphones cameras
right there
mm-hmm zoom in on his crab leg yeah yeah
we hold it closer to my I'll tell you
where you're at
thank you all right there I want to pull
out a beautiful piece of meat right
there like a perfect one that's clean
just a little every crab leg it's better
yeah I'm gonna put this on it like it
like a trophy stare hold it up well
it'll use your thumbnail oh yeah do you
like your crazy face a picture real
quick of it yeah
[Laughter]
very proud of it but yeah man I feel
like so juvenile hell was all produced
by lex luger yeah you know I'm Sam and I
was just pretty the most real [ __ ] that
could ever happen at that point in my
career that opening song is aggressive
like you know hell yeah I bro so uh I
told low B I was like yo I really want
you to be on this tape but I knew that
like him like it might have not met the
deadline for him to like get his verson
so I was just like yo like instead just
like record like a voice memo and send
it to me there's like an intro or
whatever like a skit so he was like I
had that so yeah put that put that on
top of the song at the beginning and it
was a rap dude but yeah man working with
Lex was the most surreal [ __ ] just from
like listening to him back in a day so
like making music it was like yeah I
feel like like the first like the the
first few times I had texted legs I was
like yo like is this really you yeah I
was like yo I've been listening to you
since the ninth grade yeah it's like a
weird thing you gotta you gotta like not
mark out to him too hard
and you got to kind of be cool at the
same time you kind of you got to find
the balance they don't they don't be
like yeah
yeah remember to be yourself and
remember that they're people too there's
a lot of dudes now and I'm just like
yeah I'll be texting them and I'm just
like yo just be cool yeah yeah like I'll
be texting a little be like his own
lyrics like I'll be like youngbae's guy
what does he say to you you text him
that left on red he's always like I
talked him on the phone once yeah he's
gonna come do that we're gonna do the
pie he was gonna do the episode of the
podcast but I was gonna go up to up to
him this was like two years ago
he sounds speak at the college oh yeah
we did he spoke at a symposium he did
one of those lectures at UF and
Gainesville this was like five years ago
maybe six years ago yeah yeah he yo he
was yo he was on the road with those
college lectures yeah he was it was on
real how many people packed that little
auditorium to listen to him talk yeah it
was crazy I was so sick is like he's
really and he's a big influence on on
people I can talk about it that thing I
don't know he just talked about his like
creative process how he comes up with
stuff how like he motivates himself to
create music from when he was younger to
where he is now and like where he is in
his life now like talked about like his
big life events like his house burning
down that kind of stuff I don't I was a
long time ago but it was really cool he
did he spent like the whole lecture was
maybe an hour and he spent at least
another hour just taking pictures and
talking to people afterward the People's
Champ he really is and the line at that
thing it started like eight o'clock at
night and the line at UF and to go to
that little auditorium like went out of
the whole camp it was the first time
I've been into a real college came out
the whole campus outside and wrapped
around half the building
yeah we we stole two of our friends IDs
to go get in there uf Gainesville shout
out to them yo my homie had let me
borrow little B's book his book that he
wrote at 19 right I remember listening
to little be back in the day and little
B will be like yeah like I'm the first
rapper to ever write a book at the age
of 19 blah blah blah you do a good
impersonation of them yeah yeah this is
my voice for everybody sounds little V
it's like really like genuine and like I
care and a little soft that's marvelous
no matter male female whatever but yeah
like he would be like yeah first rapper
to write a book at 19 I was like damn
like how do I get this book in like the
book is so rare it's called taking over
super rare
it's called an ultra rare yeah not it's
called taken over and I remember of a
good friend of Mines net art from he
produced a lot of stuff for Pb he's part
of GBC um I was in LA it was like two
years ago
and he was like yo I got I have that
book cuz like he's a really big little
big fan too so I was like yeah I'm
reading the book and a lot of stuff in
the book like it's so like it's it's so
like authentic dude like there's typos
in the book there's hella typos and [ __ ]
as if like he just wrote all of his [ __ ]
and it's I tuned notes just like a
stream of consciousness yeah like
there's so many like misspelled words
and [ __ ] where did he get the book I'm
not sure like I don't know where they
was selling this book when it came but
it's super yeah you can't find that [ __ ]
anywhere dude but yeah now it's so it's
so authentic and they like it basically
uh he's he's telling people like how he
started out and like
you know the base lifestyle and what
that is in like he talks about being too
short and getting signed to a label for
the first time and - yeah it's very
inspiring I saw a little bit shouts out
basedgod what was it like having
somebody like that to look up to because
I mean you even said something about
like even wearing vans was enough to get
made fun of like to have somebody who
comes out like Lil B say like no it's
okay for you to be who you want to be
yeah in this industry what was that like
it's uh it was a few people that was on
that [ __ ] too like there was like there
was like Pharrell and like any idea you
know I'm saying and you know that was
[ __ ] and there was like do like Kanye
like Kanye was so left the oddball you
know I'm saying like wearing polos and
Louis Vuitton backpacks yeah Dave
Chappelle yeah that's my first
introduction to Kanye yeah you know so
it's a handful of people that was doing
that
totally it was a few of the fire you
know I'm saying it was like all right
like it's okay yeah you don't have to
you don't have to be some tough guy it's
all the time no you know anything like
or act like you have all this money yeah
yeah no cuz a lot of these rappers are
like you're already driving a Bentley
a lot of these rappers are trying to
sell the dream and and it's so like you
know it's it's corny bro it's all
smoking here to do yeah it really is
that's the one thing that I wish would
change I don't know it's just the one
thing that I never found like cool about
the culture of the like hip-hop videos
or I mean it's not just the videos I
mean it's obviously everything about it
but it's I think it's changing but it's
always been like show that you have so
much more than what you really have and
it's always been about just like making
the money or having the cars and having
the chains having the ice all that
that's like the meat of the content for
a lot of people
I feel like I feel like that started
when cousin in 90s it wasn't really like
that like in the 90s or like mm-hmm
early 90s hiland early 90s was you know
you know I so drugs like yeah I'm
selling not he's drug you know saying
that was about that it wasn't really
about like how many hoes you know what
car you was driving yeah it was about
how hardcore like but there's also I
mean at on the other side of it there's
also like the fake it till you make it
thing you know if that's what you really
want and you want to put that out there
then that could end up being what you
want for example when I help rod wave
she wanted his first videos we let him
borrow marks Bentley because he needed a
car for it so he had a rant Mark had a
Range Rover in a Bentley and we let him
drive the Bentley down the street walk
into this store in downtown st. Pete and
he literally let him drive the Bentley
with these girls in it or whatever and
rod we couldn't afford a Bentley only
mean he had a car when we shot that
video and now I guarantee you he could
buy a fleet of Bentley's I think it's
more like aspirational and like that
whole secret thing where you just like
you will it and to exist in so you just
keep repeating it repeating it yeah for
sure eating it just convince yourself
that's gonna happen always wake up
thinking about it yeah it's definitely
it's definitely it's a goal it's a
motivation thing yeah it's a goal
motivation people they want to see that
they associate that with moving ahead
and getting to like getting out of where
they are and moving to like the next
level everyone's got a mantra whether
it's like negative whether you think
like I can't do this this isn't working
or whether your mantra is I got a
Bentley a million dollars and ten
[ __ ] whatever you think you're gonna
do and get you're gonna get event yeah
that if you think that's shallow and
lame then you know whatever that judge
people
yeah dude there's yeah man just live
your truth and be positive and don't
mess with other people